you know how sometimes somebody from the
finger lakes district of new york state
will tell you that actually they make
really good wine up there and you
wouldn't expect it because of the nature
of the terrain and you know the sun
doesn't seem to shine
all that much and so they pour you a
glass of this
finger lakes wine and it's never really
very good
i've been told that frankly i just
haven't had the right wines and i'm
open to suggestion but finger lakes wine
is always interesting to me because i
find
the languages that were spoken up there
much more interesting than the wines
what am i talking about iroquoian and
the names of many of those languages
these are the finger lakes
names they're going to be familiar and
they tell you where these languages were
spoken
cayugo or are spoken but you know
hanging by a thread for the most part
today cayuga
seneca oneida mohawk is one of these
languages erie
hurran we're in that territory these are
a family of languages they're called
iroquoian early colonists had ample
dealings
with the iroquoian confederacy
of these languages only two of them
cherokee which is spoken in oklahoma
arkansas
and north carolina and mohawk which is
spoken in canada and also in some parts
of northern new york
only they're viable nobody is afraid of
cherokee
and mohawk going away but the others
it's safe to say that
they'll all soon be extinct but
they're very interesting languages in
many ways
cherokee is relatively vital
partly because it actually is the rare
native american language
that has its own writing system there
was a silversmith a cherokee silversmith
silversmith back in the 1820s and he
didn't speak english
this is a time when it was easy to be a
native american and
still not speak english his name was
sequoia
and he was impressed by something he was
impressed by writing
it wasn't something that he had
experienced and he saw that
you could scratch something down on
paper and then
you could read off language from it can
you imagine
what a miracle it would be to experience
something like that as an adult
when you hadn't seen it before you know
to us we think that language is the
written word if i say already you can't
help but picture
already if i say dog you might even
picture dog before
you picture a little golden retriever
puppy being held back from its natural
enthusiasm but imagine if you haven't
seen that yet
and you see people looking at some piece
of paper
in some kind of concentration and
they can then mouth language based on
something they scratched on the paper
sequoia called it
talking leaves and he decided that there
are always people like this in any group
of human beings he decided
i want to do that i want to give that to
my people so these europeans have these
talking leaves i want us to have
talking leaves so he decided to create
a writing system and it's it's perfect
he did
exactly what any of us would do if we
were going to start a writing system
from scratch the first thing you would
think of
as i said about languages like the
chinese and the writing system there
first thing you would think of is you
would want to draw
little pictures of things that's what
first
occurs to anybody creating a writing
system
and then you find if you're considerate
which is not always true but you find
quickly
that that's unwieldy and it's unwieldy
both to use and it's very difficult to
learn they're just too many
words and so he realized that wasn't
going to work and he moved on
to creating not an alphabet that is not
the next thing people tend to think of
they tend to think
of syllables and so for example if you
ask
ordinary unlettered people people who
do not have literacy yet what the
segments
of their words are spontaneously they'll
say that the segments
are syllables and so if the word were
incorporation they would say well
it's in core poor a and shin they would
never say that it's
not natural so sequoia created a
syllabary
so for example in cherokee it's hanging
well that's well he decided to have
something for
and something for top and something for
ah
now where are you going to get these
symbols for syllables well he looked
at the talking leaves that he saw with
the roman alphabet
and he was not literate in english or
any european language and so he just saw
these symbols imagine
seeing the alphabet as just pretty
things and they are pretty
wouldn't you like to kind of sit on a w
and rub yourself
a little bit wouldn't you want to bite a
c
i wouldn't mind and so he's looking at
all these letters
and he's just he just grabs them he
doesn't know what order they come in he
doesn't know what they stand for
and so you know an e is for this a d is
for this and you know v
is for that that writing system exists
today and it's kind of an acid trip
looking at it because it's our letters
but you can tell that it's not
the logic that we associate with the
letters they're being used in a
completely
different system and this worked because
you know how the story is supposed to go
is that he created this system
and nobody cared and he died bitter and
alone
no pretty soon most cherokee were
literate
in this language and there's been a
whole lot of material published
in this cherokee writing system and it's
funny it wasn't only successful
with cherokee here in all place of all
places
it was also successful in liberia it
seems that
this system sparked the development of a
writing system
for a language called vai which is
spoken in
liberia vi is a language from the monday
sub-family of niger congo that's taking
us way back now monday probably is a
family of its own
but vai is unusual in languages of that
region and having its own
writing system and it's not exactly
documented how it happened but the
cherokee system is the 1820s
and this vai system emerges in the 1830s
and at that point
some cherokee for reasons i don't have
time to get into had migrated
to liberia and one of them was kind of a
prominent figure
in the area so it's fairly clear that
the cherokee writing system
was brought to liberia just one of those
things the serendipity of human history
but
there's something that's frankly weird
about iroquois
and yes i'm going to just say it's weird
because it is unusual
in the world and you know it doesn't
hurt anything but
iroquoian languages tend not to have
sounds that make you put your lips
together it's like they don't want to
put
their lips together lauren because says
you know put your lips together and blow
they apparently don't want to at least
not when they talk no puh no boo
no fu and no no just they don't want to
put their lips together keep them apart
for some reason
and so those sounds are just missing you
find out that it's a language
it has all the sorts of things you
expect the language to have some of the
things are unusual
but for some reason no things that make
you put your lips together
so you're speaking cayuga and for some
reason you're going to say
i have to make 12 shirts well the way it
goes just you don't have to know what
these units mean but the way it goes is
technique
okay that's fine but i never put my lips
together i'm going to do it again
technique
i did all sorts of things i'm not used
to doing my throat is
still tickling but i didn't put my lips
together that's just
the way these languages are so you're
speaking in iroquois language chances
are you've got some pretty
smooth lips they must not need chapstick
they just don't do certain things so
iroquoian fascinating for various
reasons
now then we're going to move on to hokan
i don't think hokan is a family but i
don't have the authority
to say whether it is i'm just pretending
because i have a baritone voice in a
vaguely
imperious manner but i'm not the only
person
who thinks including people who actually
know what they're talking about that
hokan
is really several families and they're
probably related the way you know
amaranth
languages are but some people think ho
khan is a family
but there is one general trait
about the languages that are called
hokan which
is cool in itself it's about the
prefixes
so i just you know how there there are
some
tv shows for example that you just don't
find exciting
as soon as you hear about it you just
you can barely suppress a yawn for me
that would be hogan's heroes i never
understood why that was funny
i want to yawn now that was not funny
it's not interesting
f troop is the same thing in linguistics
that would be prefixes
you don't care about them you know
because in english they don't really do
anything very interesting
so for example to read well i re-read
okay or you know i miss understood
you know it lends some you know aspect
of meaning but it's nothing that you
would leave your happy home
for the prefixes just do rather vanilla
things the suffixes are more
interesting that's not true in all
languages they're languages where the
prefixes are just
having a party so for example there
is a language called pomo and that
doesn't mean that
it has an angular hair style and a
certain way of dancing
if pomo just is po not post modern
but there's a language called pomo it's
really it's a group of languages and
this is from the central
pomo variety and it's got these prefixes
that do all these very specific sorts of
things
so you can take a vanilla verb and make
that vanilla verb
connote all of life itself and so
for example means with a handle
cha is by slicing is by poking i'm going
to give you a bunch of them because
you're going to see the magic that they
can create
is by biting i just did a uvular stop it
feels good you should learn how to do it
ah i'm going to do it again
ah so by biting ba
is orally means by fine hand action yes
i meant that
it's just a glottal stop so with your
fingers kind of finely
like you're playing an arpeggio on the
piano s is by sucking
is involving vegetative growth da
is when you're pushing something with
the bottom of your hand
is with heat like and sha is
by shaking imagine what all of those
prefixes
can do so for example yol is just some
little verb
and it just means to you know to mix so
yol to mix that's so interesting but
when you combine
yole with all these prefixes then you
get all sorts of stuff
so shi is with a handle sheol
is to stir with a spoon like to mix with
a handle okay that's that's okay
but cha is by slicing so cha yo
is to chop up several things now
huh is by poking now what do you do with
the poking well
you're poking and you're mixing yo is to
add salt and pepper because
you poke it you poke it in so ah i'm
doing a uvular stuff i'm going to do it
again
that is biting so what about biting
and mixing that's to eat several things
together so you know that kind of person
who takes their roast beef and their
potatoes and their celery and
chews it all together because apparently
they enjoy life more than i do
so it's aayo eating several things
together so they've got a word
for shoving all that stuff in your mouth
at the same time or
ba orally so how do you mix something
horribly
so biol that means that you're humming
and you're sticking little words in
baiol means that you're going nursery
maybe frankly i've never done that in my
life apparently these people did
or so by fine hand action
yo is to throw a bunch of ingredients
into a bowl
with the fingers like you're going to do
a a rub for your
barbecued ribs don't use too much cumin
people overdo the cumin there's no
reason that barbecued ribs have to taste
like india they should taste like south
carolina
or suh is sucking so
so sucking mixing is when you wash down
if you ask the speakers or ask the
speakers what it meant
it's when you're washing down cookies or
donuts with coffee
you do need a word for that we just
think of it as that crap you do with
your throat
they have seoul or that's involving
vegetative growth what does that mean
well
means when you plant things close
together you've got your squash
with your beans with your dahlia plants
etc da
is you're pushing with the palm and so
that's when you're folding in dry
ingredients while you're baking i'm sure
there's an english word for that i don't
know it because i don't like to bake but
you get the point is with heat mule
means that you're throwing a bunch of
things into the pot like when you throw
in bugs bunny in the carrots and bugs
bunny says and that what's cooking
that's mule
or shah is by shaking so chaol
is to sift dry ingredients all of that
how to
how do you create a vocabulary in the
pomo languages you had all of these
delightful
prefixes and i almost don't need to tell
you the pomo languages are either dying
or dead and yet they had something like
that imagine the joy
of learning what meanings you could
create with all of those prefixes
based on a vanilla verb like yol to mix
and then those
imagine how you could take all those
prefixes and add it to something like to
talk
or to wash or to grab or all sorts of
things now
that's a language those are languages
that's my favorite thing about hokum
and the one that i wanted to mention
because otherwise it's hard to make any
generalizations because i'll bet
it's not a family but nobody asked me
because it's not my expertise anyway
let's look at a smaller family
because there's something neat in this
family
tanoen this is one of the ones that's
kind of little
unlike these big ones that we've seen
you know it's in kansas and oklahoma and
texas
and new mexico so this is kind of
country so you get a sense of the kind
of
loss that these languages entail
in finding just little things about them
that you would never think a language
would do kiowa
is oklahoma and just singular and plural
is a funny thing if you were trying to
figure out how to say more than one of
something
this language would just bop you on the
news and so for example
skunk the word for skunk in kiowa
is tal okay so the word for skunks
is talgo so
so that's okay and so you figure there's
your your plural word
so then you you're doing horse and the
word for horse
is well
if the word for horses dot then the word
for horses is going to be probably
and it is so then you think you've got
it right and then you're looking at the
word for wing
and you find out that the word for wing
is
olga and then you think oh well no
that's the word for wings right
but no it's not the word for wings it's
just the word for wing
olga but i thought that the gal was how
you made something plural no it's just
wing
well then how do you say wings well you
just say oh
dol so
now you're imagining a cow skull you
know that that's gonna be one
sitting there and so you say okay what's
the word
for bone and they'll say well it's tall
segal
and no no not bones bone so go up
and they say no that's that's bone well
suppose there were a lot of bones and
they say well then that's going to be
offset
so what what is it gal is the pluralizer
you think
but then sometimes the one with gaw is
singular
and the plural is to not put the gall on
and it turns out that
what that gal means it doesn't mean
plural
it doesn't mean singular it means
the thing that you find least expected
and so if you're talking about a skunk
you don't see gangs of skunks there's
generally
only one and it makes you very unhappy
and so then
go means well suppose there are a bunch
of skunks suppose you find a mama skunk
with baby skunks
or something like that but then with
bones it's not usually one bone you
usually see
a bunch of bones and if there's only
just this one
bone that's unusual so gaul means
basically the opposite of the default
number
and that's the way this language works
and so it's not so crazy it's just a
very different way of being a language
than we would think of and then of
course there are two other little things
about this that i'm not going to bother
you with
but that's something that happened with
kiowa that's in our to know in
family something that we need to think
about with these
north american languages finally is the
issue of their demise and what it looks
like
because quite often when whites have
encountered these languages and wanted
to study them
the language as it is is no longer the
language as it was
and often it can be tricky to determine
what the original language
was like because what the language is
spoken as now
is somewhat decayed the people now live
primarily in probably english and if you
don't use it you lose it especially when
you're talking about languages
as complex as this and so you may
remember that when i talked about my
first
experience of persian that the man gave
me the very streamlined verb conjugation
and one question i asked him very gently
was did you grow up
speaking this because what i was
thinking was that maybe persian
wasn't his primary language and so he
was giving me
a kind of user-friendly as in maybe
slightly decayed person or maybe that he
had never actually
learned the full language in that case
because persian is really like that
but that's because a linguist is often
careful
about things like that and part of why
linguists know to be careful about
things like that
is what happens with many for example
native american languages and so for
example
this is just a demonstration groventra
as in
big belly that was an algonquian
language spoken in montana this was one
of the real westward ones and it's it's
gone now
but before its last speakers passed away
this was in the early 1980s the language
was recorded as they spoke it luckily
the language had been recorded earlier
because the way those people spoke it
even though they really did speak the
language
it wasn't the full language anymore
and so for example there's let's take
the word
duck and you're thinking like how do you
do
the the plural well the word for crane
was iteco okay the word for cranes was
so the word for duck if the word for
duck is sisiko
you'd think that the word for duck would
be titsy
but it wasn't it was now you can imagine
this is a real language and so you have
lots of these irregularities
in plurals and people weren't using them
anymore they were over generalizing one
ending
instead of having mastered all the
different rules that you use
such that there are all sorts of ways of
making a noun plural
and that is a sign of the language
disappearing
this was you have to there's an
imagination that you have to use
imagine if there were some circumstance
you went somewhere where people were
speaking english
with confidence and affection it's not
that they don't speak it
but they were saying sentences like i
think that it be the mans who were
behind the house they're trying to say i
thought
it was the men who were behind the house
and they say you know very casually oh i
think that it'd be the mans who were
behind the house
and you think what you know it's because
they no longer know those
specific arbitrary irregular sorts of
things
they don't fully command the grammar
that would be what it would be like
to speak english in this way it would be
english
on its way out or at least it wouldn't
be the english that english
ever was or something like um
to go a little further down preview of
where we're going suppose you're in el
salvador you're speaking a language
called ppu
and pipil used to have a future
ending today's speakers of ppo they
speak it but they don't use the ending
as much as they used to many of them
don't use it at all
instead they use the going to
construction and so
you can either use the ending or say i'm
gonna do it
and so you can say for for drinking if
you're going to drink in the future you
can say
nikunis you use that ending you can say
means i go i'm going to drink now if a
language is no longer the one that you
use
every day then if you say i'm gonna
drink
that's easier than saying i drink whoop
you know whatever that suffix is
because i'm gonna has meaning whereas
that suffix is something that you just
have to
memorize and internalize that has no
meaning in itself
that's the sort of thing that tends to
drop away and so
imagine if for example somebody was
saying well i did think
instead of i thought and they said well
i did walk
instead of i walked and they didn't
anymore have any kind of difference
between saying well i did walk
as opposed to i walked which are really
two different things instead they just
always say i did walk
that would be a different english and it
would be in english that was becoming
ever less
what it was that's what a lot of these
native american languages become like
as they're on their last gasps many of
the iroquoian languages are recorded
as having that kind of problem from
their final speakers so you really do
see the
the breakdown of a system
now when we talk about breakdown of a
system
that relates to something else that
we've already seen
which is pigeons and that's something
that we want to look at before we close
because you might wonder these 300
different languages
how did people communicate in
with each other when they needed to and
so yes you could have an interpreter but
suppose there wasn't anybody like that
and suppose
the communication was more frequent than
you would expect interpreters to be used
for
and there were various things that
people did and so for example you may
have heard of the plains
sign language that sign language was one
way that people who spoke very different
languages
could communicate and that was very
popular in the middle
part of north america but then as you
can imagine
there were also pigeon varieties so
especially with languages this
complicated
the people weren't going to learn each
other's languages and they didn't need
to
but if there was going to be a lot of
communication between groups a lot
of trade and maybe other kinds of
relationships then naturally
there were going to be pigeons and
various ones are recorded and so for
example
chinook was a massively complicated
language
up in the pacific northwest and the
chinook also had a certain
socio-political dominance
so there are many very different
languages spoken up in the pacific
northwest
and what happened was that there was a
pigeon
based partly on chinook and almost as
much really on another language in the
area called
nutka and this pigeon was used among
people
there and it was also used by french and
then english speakers who came into the
area if you're a french or an english
speaker frankly you're not going to
learn
chinook but there can be a chinook
pigeon so
chinook itself was one of these
languages with sounds that it's hard to
make if you're not born into them
and a very very complex set of prefixes
and suffixes
but the pigeon was called chinook jargon
and it was very widely used for a long
time and sometimes even used
in writing and that was you know that
it's a pigeon even if you don't know
chinook so the beginning
of the lord's prayer in chinook jargon
was our father who live in above good
your name
wasn't psychopath like
right there yes nem was named that was
taken from
european languages of course but yeah
justin sakapapa likes to meet like
so that's what it was and you can see
i'm not going through the herculean
effort
to mispronounce these languages that
you're hearing when i'm
speaking trying to speak the other
native american languages this one
really the hard stuff was beautifully
leeched out it wasn't a full language
moby dick and chinook jargon would not
really be
very effective but it was a great way to
communicate among people who needed
to keep things relatively practical but
do more than you can do
by just having say 10 or 11 signs
whereas plain sign language was very
much a pigeon of its own
but just done with the hands now of
course
chinook jargon is up in the pacific
northwest
the pacific northwest is just one part
of the united states
and there were various other jargons of
that kind
there was a quote-unquote eskimo jargon
up north
for example there was what was called
mobilion jargon another example of
language like that
pidgin that was spoken in the
southeastern united states
and then there was delaware jargon i
mentioned before
that in the new york area the language
that was originally spoken was called
muncie muncie was one flavor
of what in the larger sense could be
called the delaware language depending
on what you call
language and what you call dialect and
there was
a delaware-based pigeon that was used
among
native americans in the area and very
much was taken up by europeans there
were swedes
who were quite proficient in this
broken down makeshift version
of languages like muncie where the
grammar is vastly simplified there's
barely any grammar at all
and you just have a relatively small
collection of words
and it's interesting delaware jargon was
so spontaneously used
outsiders that william penn comes in
and he does various things he found
pennsylvania but he actually also was
interested
in the quote-unquote native peoples and
their languages and he wanted to know
what this language that they were
speaking was and so he's
taking down what he thinks of his actual
delaware
language and it's in exquisite detail
he's clearly listening very closely
to the sounds and it turns out that they
weren't giving him the delaware language
at all
they were giving him the pigeon and it
wouldn't have occurred to them that he
would have wanted to know
their actual language because he sure as
heck wasn't ever going to learn it
instead they just gave him their words
and they gave him their sentences
and he thought that that was delaware
itself we can look now
into his journals and say wait a minute
this is a pidgin language this isn't
anything like
what muncie and unami and related
languages actually were
you never knew but the sense was that if
you're with outsiders you're not going
to use
your language but you're going to use
language it's just going to be
a simplified version of it to them that
was the way these things were negotiated
in any case i could be accused of a kind
of
northocentrism here because i'm talking
about these native american languages
and
you might think that for some reason
everything stops at the rio grande
but no people went further down south
and they kept speaking languages and
goodness they've left an awful lot of
them
with stories to be told i will tell them
in the next lecture
[Music]
you